something that i thought viewers might
find interesting since all of us can
probably relate to this is my experience
and my views and
my background with with work i've worked
quite a few
jobs in my life of quite different sorts
and so i thought it could be interesting
to talk a little bit about that and as i
started thinking about this there were
a few things that came came to mind some
general things
one is that you know a lot of people
have
jobs that they they don't find
particularly fulfilling
and they're unable to to find
themselves in in their work or you know
what they
they walk away with at the end of the
day they feel drained
they don't walk away with a sense of
satisfaction they feel you know as we
call it alienated
and i worked quite a few jobs like that
in the course of my
my life i'm fortunate that you know i've
arrived at a point where i have pretty
fulfilling work
but it's not always been the case
another thing that was that that i
recalled and i originally wanted to
attribute this to henry miller but as it
turns out you know after
checking it on the webs it's actually a
quote by by william faulconer who says
one of the saddest things is that
the only thing a man can do for eight
hours a day day after day
is work you can't eat eight hours a day
nor drink for eight hours a day nor make
love for eight hours
all you can do for eight hours is work
which is why man makes himself and
everybody else so miserable and unhappy
and that's kind of an interesting
sentiment
i think there's a there's a truth to it
that you you can't
day in day out simply engage in
pleasurable activities that that don't
produce
anything that don't change anything
nor can you just um you know eat or
drink or
or anything like that i suppose you
could you know sleep 16 hours a day
the way cats do but that wouldn't be
much of a life
so you know one reason why we have to
work
is because it it helps keep us on track
but but it's very important not only to
just do a job
if you want to be happy but to find
something that
that you can locate yourself within that
that is meaningful to you
and when i started thinking about about
work
and i started thinking about you know
the first jobs that i had
i kept on having to go back further and
further and further and further and
further
because you know quite frankly i don't
remember a time where we weren't doing
something and it wasn't necessarily
remunerative work you know even in the
sense of getting an allowance whether
i'm
getting a paycheck but when i was a kid
everybody had chores
not only did we have chores but
everybody on our block had chores
um and there was always something that
that needed doing you know we had an
acre yard
with uh not only a lot of a lot of grass
but a lot of landscaping and a lot of
things that
needed to be done we had probably
uh about an eighth of an acre of that
was was garden and then there was all
the housework
and i remember as a kid my dad was a
very hard worker
he was actually a tax attorney
his father before him had been an
extremely hard worker as well
had a very you know short education as a
kid and immediately went to work and
eventually became
for a short time a prize fighter and
got out of that as soon as he started
getting knocked out and changed his name
and went to work for
for uh various companies and eventually
became a main consultant to the to the
glidden corporation
and he would go and set up plants in
europe and he wanted for my dad
something something different something
where you didn't have to scrabble quite
so hard but my dad ended up becoming
this this tax attorney
who you know i meant he got a law degree
and he had a cpa
and i remember he worked very very hard
particularly during tax season we
wouldn't see him for more than a few
glimpses for
about four months because he would drive
the hour commute to work
and drive back and he was arriving at
home
later than we were going to sleep and he
was he was leaving earlier in the
morning
than we were waking up and if he was
around on the weekends usually
he had brought some some work home with
him
and his work is what made our entire
lifestyle possible
at the same time i remember him spending
an awful lot of time with us so it's you
know
it's interesting to think back about
this there's kind of a cut-off point
because he died when i was 11 and i'll
do another video about that sometime
my mom had held different jobs and
actually
she she did continue to work part-time
uh
you know for instance doing sales at
pennies and things like that
but for the most part she she worked in
the in the home
and you know in her case being a
housewife was
a real job i mean for one thing
while my dad was still alive she cooked
just amazing meals
with you know quality ingredients
everything cooked from scratch because
that was just the way you did it you
know they had grown up
essentially you know lower middle class
and made it into
the middle class and we're even you know
upwardly mobile into the
the upper middle class and they carried
forth this intense
you know you you make use of everything
you you
work and do things all the time you
don't let time go to waste and then you
know when you have time to enjoy
yourself
you've cleared everything away now you
can just enjoy yourself
and so there was always something to do
and i remember as you know being very
little and already doing vacuuming
and helping out with cleaning windows
doing weeding that was a big thing there
was always weeds to be pulled
working in the garden august and
september meant
canning processing the food for for the
winter that was to come
and so i remember myself and my sister
who was about two and a half years
younger than me
always having something to do
sweeping you know vacuuming like i said
mopping the floors
eventually my mom taught us how to do
our own laundry which was which was very
good that came much
much later and
then of course when my dad died things
changed and my mom
eventually had to go back to work and
she started out
in working in an office supply store
that one of the neighbors had
in waukesha we were living in waukesha
at the time
and eventually she found you know work
as a secretary and worked her way up
through the ranks and became you know a
pretty important you know
what we would nowadays call a personal
assistant
so i had some really good models for
myself and you know everybody in my
larger family
if they weren't working it was because
they were retired
and even when they were retired they
they constantly found things to do you
know i spent a lot of time
out in the summers with my my
grandparents and
great aunt and uncle and all of them
worked all the time there were always
things to do you know working on the
tractor
tilling an even larger garden taking
care of the garden you know weeding
my great uncle kept bees and we would
have to do a lot of different things
with that
and there was never this sense that work
was something
you know terrible or to be avoided
it was you know look there's this this
cool thing to do over here and this cool
thing to do over here and this to do
here
and it would cut into your play time but
it wasn't
onerous in any any sort of sense
i would say that my first real paid job
started when i was about maybe 12 or 13
so not not that long after my dad died
and by then i was cutting the grass and
i'd been cutting the grass
and also clearing the snow
you know with the tractor
it must be going back to like when i was
nine or ten i would guess
and anyway i would cut the grass and
after a while
my mom actually started paying me to cut
the grass and back then
for cutting the acre of grass not quite
an acre because there was a house out in
a garden and all that
i would get two bucks or three bucks
and i remember that was two bucks that's
right because i remember my neighbor
the next door neighbor who also had an
acre she came to me and she said i'd
like to
hire you to cut our grass i guess her
girls weren't really into
mowing grass her husband didn't like
doing it or she didn't like doing it
and there was this big scene because
she asked me how much i wanted for doing
it
i was thinking well i get two bucks so
i'm gonna really jack it up
you know and really go for the gold i'll
do it for three bucks
and she got angry at me and she she
actually
i didn't realize this at the time she
wasn't angry at
me per se she was angry at what was what
was going on because she felt that my
mom was kind of
you know ripping me off and she said
you know you can't do it for three bucks
you know i will give you either dollars
or fifteen dollars so you decide
on what kind of a job you want to do for
that
and you know i thought wow that's that's
a ton of money at the time
that actually you know was quite a bit
you could buy a pack of gum for
for 25 cents gas was a buck a gallon
just to give you an idea you know this
is back in the early 80s
so anyway i started cutting grass for
them and
you know when it would snow particularly
heavy
i and a few of the other boys would get
together and go shovel people's drives
and see if they'd give us some money for
that
um sometimes they'd give us five bucks
sometimes they'd give us 10 bucks
sometimes they'd give us nothing other
than
a thanks but that's we did
and then my my first you know
job where i had a paycheck coming to me
not cash under the table
was working for the ywca ca in waukesha
and i'm not i think i must have seen a
want ad in the newspaper
you know we got the waukesha freeman at
that time
and they were looking for people that
they called teen peer educators
and so these were going to be kids who
would go in and
talk to other kids younger kids in in
schools
about um you know matters having to do
with sexuality
and it was it was trying to promote
abstinence it was
it was on this grant to try to do you
know promote this idea that well
you're better off you know there is
contraception out there but you're
better off just being abstinent
and here's how peer pressure is going to
come to bear on you and i guess waukesha
had a lot of problems with teen
pregnancy at the time
so they got this grant to do that and it
was kind of interesting because we got
paid first to go
to like several weeks worth of classes
and we got paid for that whole time so i
was like well this is this is great i
like being in class anyway
and you know you got to meet kids from
other schools by then i was in high
school i was
going into sophomore year of high school
so then what it consisted in through the
year was going to these meetings
and i would ride my bike into waukesha
from from wales
um taking the the you know the converted
drumlin trail and
bike to to the y and then sometimes i
would catch a ride home with my
my mom um who was working in waukesha as
well
um so i was you know i was learning to
be very reliant
to show up to to do what was needed to
transport myself to you know
make sure that i was on track with
everything that my job required
and then during the school year the teen
peer educator program meant that i would
i would get paid to go into schools and
talk with these kids and do the you know
the song and dance that they
they wanted us to do which i wasn't
particularly into
you know i thought that the not telling
them about contraception was probably
not a great idea but we were allowed to
do that if the kids came up and
asked us so that was a that was a decent
job it didn't pay an awful lot it was
minimum wage actually a lot of my jobs
that i've worked
for for a while were minimum wage and
back then minimum wage was like 335 an
hour
then my junior year
for a summer job my mother
knew this guy through the office supply
store
who had a janitorial service and i went
to work for him
at nights um didn't have a car at the
time so
so he he would actually um
drop me off or my mom would would pick
me up at places
and it was a lot of hard work
and turned out that the guy was a crook
later on we found this out
he ended up firing me in part because i
didn't i didn't move fast enough and i
thought i was moving pretty fast
for for this this job that i had but
apparently it wasn't it wasn't fast
enough for him and i remember
with that job working in all these
office buildings and getting transported
from here and here and mopping a lot of
floors and vacuuming a lot
and always having these headphones on
and at that time i was listening to a
lot
of uh classic van halen stuff and rat
anyway i got i got fired from that and
then my my next job down the line
was working at a walgreens and
i was still doing the teen pure educator
thing um
the walgreens job i ended up quitting
and then getting fired from ironically
and it was basically just stocking
shelves and doing the cash register and
that sort of sort of business
um and it was kind of cool because i got
again i got to meet a lot of people from
from other places it wasn't like the
janitorial thing where it was just this
guy and his wife and
whoever else he'd hired and we'd show up
to places
instead i was getting introduced to the
world of
of you know work where people would like
say hey what are you doing after work
and uh let's go over there and people
would get together
but i you know in my family it was a big
tradition that we would always get
together for for christmas
and christmas meant going down to
indiana where where the big homestead
was
the compound you could say where my
grandparents
had built their their retirement home
and my
great aunt and uncle theirs right next
door and another great aunt and uncle
next door and so all my my family would
converge there
and they wouldn't give me off for for
christmas eve or christmas day
so i said well i you know i'll give you
a week then
and they said forget it if you're only
going to be here for a week your
attitude is going to be bad
get out of here so after christmas i
came back
and by now we're looking at my senior
year of high school
and um i
got a job at kentucky fried chicken
at that time it was in waukesha at the
very very east end of waukesha and
waukesha is a fairly
sizable city by now we'd actually have
moved to waukesha so it was about
two miles walk from from our house to
this
this uh kentucky fried chicken and i
would catch the bus i would go
after school i would go down to the y
and i would work out
for a couple hours take a shower get
dressed get on the bus
take the bus out to kfc close the place
along with some of the other guys and
either i would get a ride from my mom or
i would get a ride from somebody else or
i would walk home
and i i actually ended up walking home
you know you don't you don't think about
this being dangerous at the time but i
walked on the interstate
on i-94 to get home because that was the
only way to
to get there at least that didn't
wouldn't take me
really far out of my out of my way
so i worked that for a while i didn't
really like that job that much because
uh
it was really messy grease was
everywhere
i got all you know i got to know some
some of the people who worked there but
there was a lot of drama
one of the managers actually uh robbed
the till
one day and then like god got you know
arrested
and i didn't really like it too much i
mean i liked that i liked the chicken at
the time
and i liked the fact that i got to bring
stuff home
after work you know i had a ravenous
appetite because i was working out quite
a lot
and so you know that was kind of a perk
so then after school ended
um a friend of mine from high school he
was working at ponderosa and he'd been
there for a while he said why don't you
come to work at ponderosa
you know it's cooking but it's not just
like putting stuff into friars
and you know waiting around and
marinating stuff it's it's actual real
grill cooking so i said
okay i'll do that so
got a job at ponderosa again you know
minimum wage kind of job
and i did just about everything in the
place except for wait tables because i
don't really like
service that much i
washed dishes i prepped i
was a grill cook
and you know you did filled out in a lot
of different ways and there was kind of
a place where there were a lot of people
who were just sort of on their way to
other things you know students
and then there were some people who were
going to be there you know
the rest of their life at least in the
restaurant industry
doing one thing or another and we would
you know have cookouts after work
and uh you know flirt with each other
and drink and all that sort of stuff
sometimes i'd go to bars even though i
was underage because i looked old enough
where some of the guys from from the
place were going to parties
and um it wasn't bad there was you know
quite a bit of drama here and there with
this guy's girlfriend don't look at her
you know that that sort of nonsense but
um
for the most part it wasn't bad the
managers weren't bad
it was it was fairly enjoyable and
it was you know interesting to get to
see all these people and so
then after that i went in the army and
that was a whole different kind of uh
experience
uh maybe i'll do a video about that down
the line sometime
uh i enjoyed certain asp i'll say this i
enjoyed certain
aspects of the military a lot i found
other things just utterly
insane repugnant irritating beyond
belief
i think some of that had to do with the
the time and place that i was in i was
in
you know a peacetime unit in the uh
early 90s and they really didn't have
much of an idea what to do with with you
know with combat troops during peace
time
so a lot of the guys were just getting a
lot of trouble and i got in some trouble
but not a ton of trouble i mean not
compared to what some of these other
guys were
getting into but there was it was you
know there was a lot of great things
that i
i learned from from the military and i
really enjoyed some of the the
friendships that i i formed
uh and then there was some stuff that
was just crazy bs
um so anyway i got out of the military a
bit early
i got out during the budget cuts of 1990
the peace dividend
and it was kind of fortunate in a way
because desert shield started not too
long after that
and my unit then actually did did deploy
to
to iraq and sat around for six months
before the shooting war started
and unfortunately they'd gotten rid of a
lot of the good
ncos during that that peacetime dividend
you know
cutting the troops kind of thing and
they kept a lot of the what we call kiss
butters you know the
people who are you know always pressing
their uniform and shining their boots
but really didn't know they're
they're on the west very well um so i
don't know it might not have been
so hot going off to war with the ncos
that they
they still had anyway i got out
and um
you know i needed to to find a job right
away uh
to bring in some money you know my mom
started charging me rent as soon as i
turned
as soon as i finished high school even
though i was 17
and it was good because it taught me
responsibility it taught me to start
budgeting and all that
so i got out and i was i was living at
home and
started looking in the wanads and going
around to places
you know sending applications and there
was a shaky's pizza
place right down the road so i applied
there
and you know right away got a job there
and that was you know same sort of
restaurant thing except now it was
uh not grill cooking but pizza cooking
and doing a lot of things for the buffet
i actually started the first thing i
started doing was prepping the buffet in
the morning
and then i would bartend uh during the
day that was kind of fun learning how to
tap beer and you know
pour wine and you know run the register
and then you know after a while i was
pretty much doing everything in the
restaurant i learned how to do every
single job in the restaurant
except for manage and i wasn't very
interested in that
they talked to me about that but i
didn't i didn't really feel like i
wanted to do that
and after you know um
after being at shakies from march
it was there from march until august and
then i went to college
and while i was at lakeland college i
did a work study
you know they hire students for these
kind of pretty easy jobs you know
um and they're some of them kind of make
work the job that i had
and it was for the art department god
only knows how they put me in there
and they had me doing two things at
first one was like you know being a
guide in the art gallery which is kind
of cool because i you know i could like
sit there and read
because hardly anyone came in there and
then if anyone actually did and they
were interested in art i could talk
about art with them
and i got to meet the artists who'd done
the uh the exhibits so that i could i
could you know
speak intelligently about it and then
they had this this
just i mean honest-to-god dirtbag guy
who was a carpenter working for them who
later on opened up a porno shop downtown
this is in sheboygan um during my
college days
and he was very seedy kind of guy but he
was a good carpenter
and so i would i would um work with him
in making you know various frames and
things like that whenever they they
needed that because i was good at
carpentry
one of the things i didn't mention
actually is i worked with my uncle
um you know cash money jobs as a
carpenter
and painter for a short time as well
when i was like 16 i
roomed with him he was rooming in a
places you know a whole different
state and hung out with him it was kind
of a good experience of life he was you
know
a fun uncle to hang out with anyway
going back to that
so i did that for a while and then my
second semester there
they they had a position for an artist
model
and so that's actually what i did and
the funny thing is you know you think
artist model you know totally nude well
it wasn't totally nude
because it was a united church of christ
school
which is about as far left as you can
get in the christian spectrum
but they still have like some things
that they were kind of you know
uncomfortable about some things that
they actually had some doctrine about
and one of them was you can't have nudes
you know there was a big thing about
nudes in the art gallery at one time
so i modeled with a swimsuit a mospito
at that time i was you know in amazing
shape i was like 190 pounds
and you know i had worked out all the
time and that sort of thing
um and that was kind of fun i didn't get
paid that much in part you would have
gotten paid more if it was
if it was fully nude but um and that was
tough work i mean you think that being
an artist model is easy
you got to take a pose and then you stay
in that pose and you can't move
and if you do move the artists start
complaining and saying
keep your foot still because they want
to they want to sketch you or paint you
or
you know something like that and i
actually ended up doing that throughout
my um throughout my college years
uh to make money here and there
sometimes for classes sometimes for for
individual things you know somebody had
a project and they needed somebody
with my build and shape and all that
sort of stuff
uh what else did i do oh yeah i had a
whole succession there was a summer
where was the succession of jobs i
started out working in this factory
called jl french
and they made aluminum diecast parts and
i started out working on this machine
called
blaster and that was back breaking work
but it wasn't bad because i was again it
was in really good shape
they would often want you to work 10
hour
12 hour 14 hour shifts you know but they
would give you overtime
pay wasn't very good it was like 6.25 an
hour
but you know for that kind of work
that's kind of hard work for that that
price but
um it wasn't bad the what the reason why
i decided i didn't want to work there
anymore is they
started putting me on these other things
like you know the testing booths which
are which are all
water and there's like water sloshing
all over you my feet would get really
you know and start to hurt by the end of
the shift and i thought ah this is this
is this kind of
this isn't for me um then they also had
me like learning how to be the tape and
band man and they apprenticed me
to this guy who was just like a meth
head
he i remember working another job he
would come in and back then you could
sell this this
ephedrine stuff over the counter he was
just totally addicted to it he'd
shake like this of course not the best
trainer you can imagine
totally all over the map and
so my girlfriend at the time
her father knew this guy who had a tree
cutting service so i quit the jail
french job
and i went to work for this tree cutting
service and at first it was pretty good
but then i realized i'd gone from bad
dwarfs
this guy was absolutely insane
and it was cash money but this guy was
just
repugnant we would start out each day
and um i would show up you know like
seven in the morning or so he'd still be
drinking his coffee and watching the tv
shows and yelling at the tv
and then he'd get on some tirade and it
might be about the blacks or it might be
about the gays or it might be about this
or it might be about that
and you got to realize wow this this guy
is just like some
way far right wacko and you know i'm
i'm not you know a liberal but
i have a you know fairly low tolerance
for people's bs
particularly if it's just spouted bs and
has no basis in reality other than the
person's emotions
and so this guy was was kind of you know
irritating
i did like the fact that i was you know
working with a wood chipper
and chainsaws and stuff like that and i
i enjoy
that kind of kind of physical work um
but i couldn't stand this guy and then
the people he'd hire to work for him boy
they were a bunch of characters
and none of them were as bad as him but
you know
they were they were pretty crazy so i
worked for him for
i worked for him for about three weeks
too and then finally one day you know
the wood chipper
um i was at a job in in plymouth and the
wood chipper just you know
got stuck and it wouldn't start up again
i said the hell with this
dro i it was kind of cool because i also
learned to drive a dump truck too
while i had that job i learned to drive
the truck that we hauled the stuff with
drove the stuff back
left it there got in my car and said
screw this guy and
my girlfriend was pretty ticked because
she came from a family where you never
are without a job
i was raised well you always need to
find a job
but it's not that you have to have a job
before you find another job
you know your job is not your whole life
it's how you make your money and you
want to be reliable
so the next job that i found was
actually working at walmart
and walmart was quite a bit different
back then it wasn't these super walmarts
like you see nowadays with the produce
and all that
and the job opening was
for working in sporting goods in
automotive and i had to work there
in part because at that time walmart was
gender divided you could say women could
work in certain areas and men could work
in certain areas of course
women could work in any of the areas
that men were working but men couldn't
work in those so men couldn't work in
jewelry
men couldn't work in women's apparel and
here was the most interesting thing
men could not be cashiers we could work
behind the cash register if need be we
were trained on that
but we couldn't be cashiers so they put
me in sporting goods in automotive
and in some respects it wasn't a great
fit
because i don't know anything about cars
and i don't really care much about cars
and i'd have these gear heads have come
in and they'd be waiting all these
products that we sold
they'd asked me about is this going to
improve this and is this going to
improve this
and at first i'd like try to reason it
out with them or i tell them
look i don't know and then after a while
i realized
it doesn't matter what i tell them
they're either going to buy the product
or not so i just yeah that's going to
make your car
run perfect and the the sporting good
stuff
i was pretty good at that i understood
you know how those things worked
and we also sold a lot of guns and
ammunition which was kind of interesting
you could you couldn't sell a person a
gun and ammunition
and have them walk out with it at the
same time
if they bought both of them somebody
would have to carry the ammunition out
while they carried the gun out
but um yeah we did that and so that was
kind of interesting
but i didn't really like walmart that
much i did a lot of stocking shelves too
the thing i really hated about is i had
to wear a tile the friggin time
and a shirt and a tie you know
and it was minimum wage and so
started looking for whatever i could
find and fortunately enough
by now it's my my junior year in college
i became a security guard working for
the college and they just started this
new security corps
eventually i became the uh the shift
coordinator for the
for the second shift and um i i really
liked the job i had the run of the
entire campus i had keys to everything
admittedly i used some of the time
and some of the keys for things that i i
shouldn't do
like you know um you know having
breakfast early in the morning when i'd
get hungry but i was on the meal plan
anyway
or you know sneaking a girlfriend in
here things like that
um play you know going into the music
music area to play my base late at night
you know to sound proofed area
you know um but you know for the most
part i did a pretty good job
and it was it was kind of fun and i
enjoyed it
had some run-ins with some some real
jerk students a lot of people made made
threats you know these these uh sort of
milwaukee gangbangers from time to time
but nothing ever came of that in part
because
back then i was you know still a little
bit
you know still the military kind of
attitude and people didn't really
bother me so i did that all the way
through uh
through the rest of my school and then
once that that
year was finished i did that the next
summer and did that the next year
then after graduating i decided i wasn't
going to go to graduate school right
away
and i roomed with a friend in a little
town just down the road called franklin
and i got a job in howard's grove at a
gas station
working behind the counter at the gas
station and basically selling people gas
and processing their credit cards back
then everything was done by hand
turning the pumps on you know to turn
the pumps on by hand
selling uh all sorts of you know stuff
we sold beer
and uh you know cigarettes and ephedrine
and and snacks of different sorts
we had a trailer park next door and a
lot of the underage kids in the trailer
park could try to come over to buy
cigarettes that was kind of an issue
where they try to steal beer and all
that
and that wasn't a bad job at first but
it came to be a bad job when they
changed managers because i spent a lot
of time
you know during the down time i was
working the second shift
i would write letters and i would you
know work on my french and work
on my german and listen to music and
stuff like that
and they had a video camera that would
watch us all the time so this new
manager came in
and she said no writing no writing
letters no reading
no doing this no doing that and i said
so
what are we supposed to do during the
dead time she said you can dust shelves
and i said well you can stick it
no way i'm dusting shelves so i did that
and then
i needed to find another job and my mom
at that time was saying look you know
there's nothing up there for you you're
done with college up there there's all
these
dead-end jobs up up there and the
sheboygan you know
howard's grove that area come back down
to the milwaukee area
and let's see what we can do so i moved
my stuff down and stayed for
about a week my mom by then had moved to
menomonee falls which is a suburb of
milwaukee
and i founded an apartment downtown
pretty quickly
and i went to a temp agency that was my
first time for doing that
so i went to a temp agency and they
hooked me up with a job
out in brookfield which was at a
mortgage company
and that one only lasted three weeks the
reason was because these mortgage
companies were bundling together
mortgages back in the
mid 90s they were bundling together
mortgages
into these you know anywhere from one
million to 50 million dollar packages
and selling them to investors and the
interest rates changed i don't remember
exactly you know what the what the thing
was but whatever it was
it made their business model uh
unfeasible and
the job was was ended the entire place
closed down
and i remember thinking to myself thank
god because as a clerk
in a place like that man it was soulless
it was it was a sort of a vision of what
my life could be like
if i didn't you know get myself off that
career track
so then i ended up in an apartment
little rat trap apartment in downtown
milwaukee
that i had to come up with 280 a month
for
and no job so i started immediately
looking in the milwaukee area and i had
a couple interviews i started doing
security stuff
one was a security job in alverno and
that's an all-girls college and
once once i started researching it i
found that security guards did not last
long there in part because it was all
sorts of
problems that they were having and then
the other one was in this
massive office building which is still
downtown called the 100 east building
and i got a third shift job and that was
really cool
because i would go into this high-rise
building
has 34 floors
and it's pretty expensive real estate
and you could like look out over the
entire city
and that was one of the perks of the job
just getting to do this as i walk my
rounds
i would walk seven miles a night on the
job and i walked in a mile and a half
there and a mile and a half back so i'd
get in 10 miles of walking a day
i had plenty of time for reading for
working on my languages
i liked some of my co-workers some of
them i i didn't like at all and one i
almost got in a fight with
because he was kind of a jerk
but you know it wasn't a bad job and i
was you know
able to squirrel away some money so i
could travel before i went to graduate
school
so that's all my pre-graduate school
stuff
in graduate school i didn't actually
have to work an awful lot
you know i was a student and i was
fortunate enough
to land myself into
positions where people were actually
giving me a stipend and paying for my
tuition
so my first three years there i was
actually on a morris fellowship this is
at southern illinois university
and the reason i think the main reason i
got it is because i maxed one of the
sections of the gre
the graduate record exam i maxed the
analytics section i got the full
high score so they thought that i had
some promise
they gave me three years and it
consisted in paying for my tuition
and giving me a thousand bucks a month i
still had to pay student fees and i had
to cover my own room and board
you know that sort of stuff but it was
it wasn't a bad existence
i lived in a trailer for a good portion
of that time
but living in a trailer wasn't too bad
you know maybe i'll tell some stories
about that sometime as well
um after that ran out then i
i ta'ed for a semester
and then after ta'ing for a semester
they said hey do you want to teach your
own ethics class
so i started teaching ethics classes
that was the very first class that i
ever taught and after two semesters of
doing that they said how would you like
to step it up to a
a upper level class a class called
philosophy of politics law and justice
perfect that's exactly the sort of thing
i wanted to do
so i taught it and i wasn't a
particularly good teacher at that time
i'll i'll do a video about
how my style has changed since then it
must have been hell for some of my
students
but anyway i did that and then i was i
started working on my dissertation so i
applied for
and received a dissertation research
award which gave me another year of
funding
and then i needed to find something and
i started out doing translation
work in latin and then working for the
the dewey center
john dewey is a major american
philosopher who studied pretty
extensively at southern illinois
so i worked for them for a semester um
and then after that i got a job working
for southeastern illinois college as an
adjunct i taught
uh an intro an ethics and a world
religions class
and that was my last semester in
carbondale
so my first semester we had moved to
indiana
and i just sent applications you know
cover
letters and cvs to every every place
within a
two hour or two and a half hour radius
and i started getting some replies
i got an offer to teach two classes at
manchester college which is located two
hours away from where i lived and i
actually took it
i got an offer to teach a class for
purdue calumet
at a local school a professional ethics
class
and then um about halfway in the summer
i got hired by ball state
to teach in their extended education
prison program
that i've talked a little bit about that
in some of my other videos
and that was a full-time job that
started out at 35
a year which at that time was not bad
starting pay for you know straight out
of graduate school i knew friends were
getting as low as you know 27
28 which is not much to live on
especially if you have a family
so
that first semester i taught eight
classes
five for ball state one for purdue
calumet
one for manchester college and i was
driving
all across indiana at the time the
prison was an hour from where i lived
the manchester which i went to two days
a week
was two hours from where i lived and i
put on a lot of miles on the car but
you know it's what you got to do when
you when you need the work
so the next semester after that i
dropped down to just teaching four
classes a semester
and then for the next five years i
taught for ball state
in the prison program and sometimes i
would teach six classes
sometimes five classes sometimes four
classes per semester
um and it was you know it was it was an
interesting job it was good
i did a lot of other things while i was
doing that you know i
i started working on my first book i
published a lot of articles i
went to a lot of a lot of conferences
and presented
i applied for a lot of jobs and
interviewed for a few jobs
you know for instance at the university
of illinois in chicago
franciscan university steubenville saint
anselm's college
just a whole bunch of different places
and
never never actually got got an offer so
um then the prison program began to end
and i had to get on the job market quick
in in the
fall the late late fall of 2007
and spring of 2008 and fortunately i i
got a job for fayetteville state
university i had one other offer at
another place
but i took the job at fayetteville state
university and that meant moving
very far away from my my family in
indiana
um 14 hours away and taking a a job and
being sort of like
almost like a military deployment so i
did that and i was at
fayetteville state university for for
three years
uh ended up there's a whole different
story about that getting getting a
divorce
for all sorts of good reasons and then
reconnecting with the woman who i knew
from high school who i would eventually
marry
my my wife who was very good
and i was down at fayetteville state
university for three years and then i
left to come up here to new york
and the reason i did that is because i
got tired of having this long distance
relationship with my my wife and
she was she was working up here and
still is so
while i was at fayetteville state
university i was an assistant professor
in philosophy mainly teaching critical
thinking classes
i took every single opportunity that i
had
any anytime they had any sort of
fellowship stipend
extra job to do i took it in part
because i needed the money you know
wages got frozen
immediately after i got hired so there
wasn't any way to make anymore
make any more money just by doing your
job well
and in part because it gave me some
really valuable job experience i
started a business ethics program not
program but
a program to educate business educators
about how to teach ethics well it's
called the ethics and business education
project
i learned about the collegiate learning
assessment
and then through their academies and
then i became
a real you know policy maker
i helped write the quality enhancement
plan for fsu the things that i did with
critical thinking and
the the cla i ran institutional
assessments
um using the cla we switched from the c
base which is a
multiple choice test to the cla which is
authentic assessment of critical
thinking
and writing abilities i instituted that
with the help of a lot of other people
and then and then ran it and reported on
it
i got to write and then run a writing
across the curriculum pilot project on
close readings for
for faculty in the humanities and so
these are just a few of the things that
i
i got to do i did a few fellowships one
in service learning one in
information literacy and then i also did
publish my
my book and um started doing you know
public lectures here and there at
libraries and
doing workshops so when i came up to
to kingston new york which is where i
live now with my wife
i had a lot of really useful job
experience
i started looking around for where i
could get work and i started teaching
classes from marist college you may have
seen some of my
marist college lecture videos that's
maybe how you ended up seeing me on the
web first
and then i continued shooting more and
more videos
here in in our home office you know we
bought a chalkboard so i can start doing
uh work you know right here without
having to be in a classroom
i also do educational consulting
colleges and
universities bring me in to do workshops
to
to meet with faculty to meet with
administrators about things ranging from
critical thinking to lecture capture
to assessment of student learning to how
to infuse ethics and
critical thinking into classes and
curricula how to teach that sort of
stuff well how to assess it well
i i have a you know i i'm connected with
a lot of different projects
so that's what i do you know if i had to
say what is it that i do
at this point in time what is my work
i'm working part-time for marist college
you know teaching in the classroom and
teaching online for them
i shoot these videos that you're seeing
that that consumes quite a bit of my
time i produce other online resources
that students and lifelong learners use
and i still continue the work that a
normal college professor would do and
you know writing books
giving conference papers but i also give
a lot of popular
lectures at libraries at churches at uh
you know for businesses
clubs organizations that sort of stuff
you know i i've
finally found my my real vocation which
is to take
philosophy which is often quite abstruse
and complex and you know has this whole
historical background
and make it accessible for for
non-philosophers
i do like talking with philosophy people
but i but i enjoy
seeing non-philosophers
non-professionals
and non-academics even seeing the light
bulb go on in their head seeing them you
know
understand something and seeing that
they can they can apply it and that
it's it's worthwhile for them that it
enhances their life
that's what i'm that's what i'm doing
now so i'm pretty fortunate
to be able to do that really is my my
full-time job
where i'm going to be 10 years from now
what kind of job i'll have then
i'm not really not really sure i'm sort
of
plowing ahead with uh what i'm doing the
teaching
the writing our our consulting company
reason io through which i give my talks
and produce resources and all that that
sort of stuff
i can say this i'm happier now
than i have been in
any of the other jobs that i've had up
until this point so i think my
40s are probably going to be my my most
productive
and enjoyable working years